did you guys know that there are more
unoccupied homes in America than there
are homeless people oh really I say good
[Music]
there's this amazing story about a guy
named Michael Townsend and this dude
lived in Providence Rhode Island
Townsend sounds like a name in Rhode
Island sounds like a pilgrim last name
huh yeah it sounds like some Boston
Massachusetts show yeah Townsend yeah is
is uh so his whole thing he's a he's
like a very poor artist he lives in like
an art uh kind of colony made out of
like a what was called like a Mill Old
Mill building it ain't the brewery oh
like a cotton like a cotton milk I guess
it's kind of like that where like you
take these old buildings and then
artists like living in them you know
every state kind of has that so he's in
that community in Providence Rhode
Island and what happened to him is that
the uh person who owned that building
came up to a woman was like Hey man like
sorry but it's our responsibility to
develop this land so we're gonna have to
ask all of you guys to leave and we have
to like you know put something new here
knock this down so you know as sad as
that is for him I think it said like his
rent there was like 300 bucks a month or
something wow that's all good so they
replaced it with like some condo that
was like 1900 bucks a month so it
totally puts all these people out
um so what he did is he what's good for
the property owner yeah it's a win for
him and anyone invested in it he decides
to go
um this developer had other properties
properties right one of the properties
that the developer also owned was the
main mall in that area like a giant mall
huge all those same stores that you see
in malls except like highly successful
very crowd very very good Mall
he looks around throughout the whole
Mall this mall that he's seen being
built over the years he's seen it since
it was just wood so he's like always
passed it almost every day of his life
and he remembers certain pockets in that
mall where there was nothing ever built
this guy's a genius and take a look at
this picture he well there was like
empty space he manages to move into an
unoccupied area in the mall and live
there undetected for four straight years
what wait what yeah dude malls are
really going away aren't they
I'm just really curious how he was able
to move a couch by himself because you
know I try to move couches by myself
a furniture dolly bro him and his
friends yes friends okay and the thing
is they didn't mean to do this as a his
intentions basically were not purely uh
need a place to live he wanted to send
this message of like hey I found an
undeveloped area in your mall and it's
my responsibility to develop it so he
develops it into this living space so he
won a little bit of a petty War for four
years yeah yeah but then now that it's
out it's an excuse he's gonna get kicked
out well he's already gotten caught for
it
so he charges blah blah but there's um
he was saying that after he got caught
um so this was back in the early 2000s
but now after he was caught and
everything and people learned about the
story he would get up to six uh calls
per week asking for the rights to his
story because people want to make movies
documentaries what TV shows they want to
make a thing out of it because they
realized uh kind of like the whole way
that he was able to do this
is actually a pretty cool story it's
kind of like the next terminal you ever
watched terminal it is yeah where you
found a way to live in the airport
because here you have some like like a
lower income artists that are displaced
and then they figured out a way to exist
undetected and they didn't really hurt
anybody yeah if anything they're just
getting trespassing charges they're not
getting anything like crazier than that
but they were able to move all these
like all this not a lot of furniture but
they were able to move enough stuff to
live in this thing where do you take a
[__] and uh the mall bathroom cook stuff
oh okay so the thing that they would do
is they would uh they didn't get this
far but after the four years they were
all planning to get jobs in the mall
whoa that's so small see if they could
exist solely in the mall yeah did you
guys know that there are more unoccupied
homes in America than there are homeless
people oh really I say good
so that means every homeless person can
be housed they could be but but there's
no point giving them houses we all got
to work from right
yeah so this dude is getting uh they are
making a documentary out of it wow yeah
right now so you might be seeing
something for it but it's a it's a
pretty remarkable story
because he really wasn't trying to hurt
anybody and he's like an older guy they
didn't do anything weird they didn't do
like drugs or anything what kind of
artist is he he it says he's a a tape
artist a tape so the [__] is the tape
artist maybe that's why he's like you
[__] like duct tape and [__] yeah like
like makes art on a table what if he's
the guy that puts all the electrical
tape on the hot models no it's not that
dude the Black Tape Project no he's like
yeah here's another shot of their uh
place a place it was kind of cool it's
pretty legit yeah I mean they're clean I
can't believe that did four years
because it's so yeah if every day the
same person walks I feel like the
security or somebody would know yeah so
that's how they got but if squatters
were all this clean and they made the
place better like I don't think most
people would mind if there were
squatters like if you think about your
typical squatter right they destroy the
spot they [__] all over the ground they
tag on everything and then they get high
and have a great time and break
everything right because that's that's
kind of what it is it's they were able
to get away with it so long because it
wasn't so much of a like as weird as it
sounds it was more of a message they
were all working they were all they all
had lives and they all weren't there all
the time
like an art installation they made it
yeah it was like an art thing so they
wanted to the ultimate goal was to see
if they could exist literally as Mall
people like for years and then once they
you know got caught it was right shy of
doing that and the way they got caught
is they would have this rule where they
were like okay the four of us started
this together we never tell anybody
about this and you don't bring anybody
here only us and then at some point
someone messed up and told uh like some
foreign artist who came to town God they
brought her there it's always some
[__] rat throw some [__] and then it
just it all it did was it it just caused
more like attention a little bit and the
timing they used to have a timing
situation where they would only leave
they would come and go at specific times
where no one would be there for sure
yeah it makes sense then because they
had this extra person the timing went
off and they exited the door the same
time Security's right here
I I'm four years I am Mr Big on like
American housing is Wild on this [__]
but this is not a [__] art
installation and the idea that these
cats are like Oh Let's Line it all up
for the experiment you know they're just
living here for free what the [__]
about shut the [__] up shut up like this
is your little narrative that you built
in the post Haze like yes it's gonna
drum up attention and support and all
this stuff but dude this is this is not
like oh a social experiment or whatever
you're living somewhere for free good
good on you 50 50. it's like 50 50 yeah
it's it's 90 10 bro
I guess you're kind of busy I do wonder
why they're um like I don't know what
the reason is but like so other
countries they'll have a lot of
different affordable options right
whether it's like just a studio room for
like in Asia they have all these
situations where like you can get
something dirt [__] cheap that's just
even for their standards it's just the
room or whatever but you don't really
see that at in La so like in LA like the
cheapest you go it's still kind of
pricey oh yeah like you have to get a a
studio apartment and then the rent and
then the The Upfront money and all that
right so it's like renting a room in
someone's house exactly a renting a room
is like 700 or more now yeah so then
like I'm like what are poor folks gonna
do that don't have any help from the
government because like if you have uh
section eight if you have help from the
government if you're in the system then
yeah you have a lot of different options
but if you're like homeless you have
shelters but what if you're just like
single you want to work and maybe you
want a small space for yourself like a
container-sized house or something or
like a trailer like it's it's pretty the
the start is a lot like it's already in
the like almost a thousand and above so
like what about all the people that can
only afford like under that or dude what
about like chicks in abusive marriages
and they can't leave because there's
literally no to go and like yeah all
that kind of stuff you think about the
ramifications of all that stuff but then
you know what what can you realistically
do like when there isn't a support
system like Joe's talking about yeah
because they do have women's shelters
but then also like sometimes you have to
be on weight or like you have to be in
super severe situations or there's not
enough housing so I'm like I don't know
if it's just building laws or like
whatever because other countries have so
many options from like small rooms to
like Mansions whereas ours the the
cheapest where it starts it's not that
cheap like it's already a full
functioning like studio with kitchen
bath and it's like it's pretty luxurious
well there's like a state here I think
who is it Missouri or some [__] where
they built a bunch of Housing and they
don't have homeless people anymore
wow in America I don't know if it's
Missouri but yeah all of Missouri the
whole state yeah there was a state that
just did this they just did it yeah they
just built a [__] ton of affordable
housing and they they shoved all the
homeless people into it and I know like
other um I see this all the time where
people are getting into like container
homes uh tiny homes all that but it's
always like somewhere else and I've
never seen one like
oh I never seen one in person like in LA
like I don't know anywhere anywhere or
anyone that has a tiny home unless all
the tiny home [__] I look at on YouTube
are luxurious as [__] they're sick
they're like balling though it's always
like in like I don't know somewhere in
Indiana or like far or [__] way you
think it's because like the really
bougie people in La that they're like oh
we don't want
um affordable housing for people I have
no idea or it could be we have
initiatives but the weather's so good
the the population that is traveling is
constantly higher than faster than we
can build
you know people are looking for fair
weather because it's hard to survive if
it's [__] snowing and like crazy
weather so it could be we're constantly
getting the influx here that we can even
support on audience the hard part too is
like because our system's so corrupt in
that department affordable housing ends
up costing too much on the back end oh
yeah that's true by the end of it yeah
yeah hey it's done oh by the way it's
not open yet like the Hilda Solis uh you
know by kind of close to barbell you see
those yellow and orange containers yeah
yeah things that's homeless housing and
nobody's there and it's been done for a
long time oh it's done yeah wow it's
like four stories or whatever just
haven't filled it yet also there were a
bunch of tiny homes that were just built
in Las Vegas and oh really they
demolished them because there weren't up
to code or some [__] wow and they built
them for the homeless
wow the best and they did that in La too
a couple years ago they just keep doing
that because it like Cycles the money or
something like it's so like even though
it's like oh there's affordable housing
that wasn't affordable for the state
it's affordable for the person that
never ended up living there in the first
place it's also conveniently competition
for places like or companies like
BlackRock among these guys who are
snapping up all this cheap real estate
it's interesting interesting little
conflict of interest yeah yeah that's
what that's that's another story too
that's a whole different animal but yeah
that's crazy but we love them and we
love their advertising dollars and we
hope that they come here thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign